so first I like to thank the organizers
for inviting me and all the speakers for
the great talk talks and what I want to
present today is a joint work with to my
heart and McKinney beginning and I'm
quite excited about this piece of work
because it's a case where semantics
leads you to introduce and use a new
syntax with good properties actually it
was not ready a new syntax because when
toma into introduced this syntax is soon
realized that it has already been
introduced let's say 20 years ago but
still the semantics can proves right in
existence in taxes so it's very nice so
what we wanted to do is too far to
describe denotational semantics for
probabilistic i order functional
computation and we for this we had two
ones the first things was to represent i
order functional computation and the
second thing was to be able to include
simple probabilistic algorithm for an
easy start we will start with discrete
probability probabilities and what we
get itself is a fully abstract semantics
with respect to 22 syntax so first I
like to describe the general framework
of our semantics among all the poor the
semantics in which we can encode
probabilistic computation we have the
domain semantics and we have the
quantitative semantics that i will use
today and that comes from inner logic
there have been many people in this
group that have been involved in one of
the other and i want to to explain what
are the similarities and the difference
between the two approaches so in the
domain semantics winter prototypes as
continuous
pues so X will be a set of finite finite
states which is endowed with another
witch and cut the amount of information
that we have on the final state so for
instance if we if we want to incur to
interprets the tight net we will use the
flat domains of integers where any
integers are incomparable a and you have
a bottom element that's represent
divergence now if you want to encode
probabilities on that so you will use
the property stickman ads that will
generate all probability distribution
over this over the domain for instance
air you will have a V of n but which
will be associating to each sequences
that associate a coefficient to each
element such that the Sun is equal to 1
now to interpret programs we use cut
continuous functions that means that's
the more information we have on the
input the more information we have on
the output and here for program from
neta neta we will have a function from
integers to probably probability
distribution but now if i want to
compose to two programs i need to be
able to fit my semantics with a
probabilistic distribution so i have to
extend this function with respect to the
probabilistic minute and to do that the
syntactical do some types that see that
corresponds to this extension is this
storage operator let em be a sample of X
and I can use it as many times as I want
in n interpretation in the semantics is
like this i have x which is a random
variable to compute the probability of
having as outcome cube i will first
choose and I which are first sample my
random variable get an outcome and and
fit my program em with em to get the
resolution and I just have to remain all
the possible interactions okay so now
for the quantitative semantics we
interpret types as poetics probabilistic
spaces which are convex spaces so the we
have the basis this is a set of final
states that can be compared compared
with this one and P of X is made of
vectors with positive coefficients these
positive coefficients are encountered
for two things the probabilistic the
probability to have a result and the
combinatorics of I'd say how many ways
do I have to
to get a result so to interpret not so i
will have as basis older natural numbers
and the poetic space will be so
probability distribution over m the
difference here is just in the treatment
of the bottom element because here i
just don't explicit the weight I put on
the divergence now at Winterfest
programs I will you use analytic
functions so a program the semantics of
a program will be a function from the
probabilistic space of the inputs to the
probabilistic space of the output and we
can understand it like this so we are in
quantitative settings that means that we
take care of resources so to compute q I
will have to use let's say K times my my
input so M wilco will call its input k
times that means that I will sample
sample my random variable K times and
get n 1 and 2 and K as outcomes with
probability the product of the
probability of getting each outcome then
I feed my program with these inputs that
are used to compute you and I Sun over
all the possibilities so here we are in
a call by name setting that means that
each time em cause its input I computer
again to the outcome of X so we have
similar settings but we have different
strategy of evaluations here we have
call by value and here we have called by
name just a remark here I say an ethic
functions but there are special case of
analytic functions they are the M the
semantics of m can be written as a
series which is the same Oliver peel
them
the problematic in domain into the main
story is to find a full subcategory of
continuous disappears that is both
catagen close and close under the power
with Sigma naught V V so it's a hard
problem and I don't know if there is a
solution now anyway in the constitutive
semantics thanks to the linear logic
machinery we do have a cottage and close
category we can we are able to a twin
tirpitz probably equal probabilities but
we M sorry papa mystic spaces are
domains analytic functions Ascot
continuous but we don't solve this
problematic because our category is not
for there are Scott continuous functions
that are not an idea anyway we still
have a nice result which is the full
abstraction of this semantics with
respect to a probabilistic extension of
PCF which is a pure functional
programming language in this setting
probably stick full abstraction means
that two programs are the same same
semantics if an aleve in any context
they will converge with to the same
value with exactly the same probability
okay so now we have the general
framework we can move to more details on
the on the semantics so we first defined
the object of my category which are
probably six paces so as I said we have
the web which will be the indices of our
vectors and we have a convex space which
is a set of vectors with positive
coefficient and we asked to thing on
that the closure which can be understand
like this so this pairing is the the
quantity of interaction between a
program you and under an environment v
the orthogonal of p is then the set of
environments that will interact with the
set of pro with the programs in p in
probabilistic way and what we ask is
that the double orthogonal of p is equal
to p so that's the first condition and
the second condition is the what I call
Bandar bandage covering it's a technical
condition that ensure coefficients to
remain fri to to be finite because when
we we use the linear logic machinery we
win it's possible to generate infinite
coefficients because programs will be
interpreted as matrices with infinite
indices and when we compose you compose
them you could have infinite coefficient
appearing but with this condition you
will have always finite coefficients as
I said before you have a probabilistic
space so if an onion if you have this
technical condition and you have a
domain which is convex
let's look at some example but so well
it's a print same one we have just one
index and the domestic space will be all
the distant for boola you will have to
index indexes and the probabilistic
spaces will be personal meaning that p
is the probability of getting true and Q
is the priority of getting one for not
you will have the superb icity the
probability distribution so add base
types we will you really have an
intuition that follows probabilities but
when you move to higher order even for
first order functions you you lose this
intuition here the the indices of the
vectors will be fine at multi sets of
true and false and the the poetic space
will be operators that preserver
probably probabilistic spaces so that
with some vectors in this policy space
to this probabilistic space here you can
see that it looks like an analytic
function in two different variables
now for the morphisms I just before
going to them of moving to the muff isms
I want to give you the general framework
of linear logic so in the neurologic you
have a linear category whose objects
here are probabilistic spaces and
morphisms a linear functions this
category is a symmetric manera dial
close category we buy product and you
can build on this category an
exponential which is a common other such
that for each object a bang a is
equipped with a symmetric common area
structure thanks to this common are you
will be able to compute the nonlinear
category the class c category whose
object our probabilistic spaces and
morphisms are analytic functions so we
we get catagen close category in which
we can interpret for obesity tcf you see
here that this encoding of the
exponential is already using the call by
name setting because what you are doing
is a program of this type we use a bunch
of input to compute its output okay so
let's move to details to the linear
category morphisms will be mattresses
index by the disease of the the input
and the indices of the output and what
we ask is that these matrices our
operators that preserve for realistic
spaces this is just the matrix product
for instance if we look at the more fees
and from night to night so we will get
stochastic matrices just by applying
this definition
now to go from the linear world to the
naw nee naw one we need the exponential
it is defined as follows the genesis of
the the vectors will be finite multisets
and the probabilistic space will be
generated by these vectors which ex is
in this probabilistic space and the
exponential exponential of x a' is
defined as follow the probability sorry
the coefficient associate associated to
this finite multiset is the
multiplication of these coefficients so
that means that the exponential
exponentiation of exa can be seen as a
bagger of copies of x for instance if i
have a point p which gives you a tool
with 480 p + 4 3 4 80 1 minus p and i
have a bag of such konsa i will get no
coins we probably wanna if i don't take
any anymore and if i take two balls and
we get twice through with priority
peer-to-peer x p
this experiments on this exponential we
can construct a common error with
components like this and for each X we
have a symmetric common community that
means that we have a contraction that
allows you to duplicate vectors in here
and the covina quickening that allows
you to erase things in bangles okay so
now i can define the nonlinear morphisms
i will just combine the definition of
linear morphisms and of the exponential
so i just replace here the indices by
finite multiset and i replace here the
vectors by vectors in this probably
stick space okay what is nice here is
that we have a density theorem which say
that to know if such a mattress is a
morphism in my class three category i
only have to test it on the
exponentiation of x for x in here so i
don't have to test it for any vectors in
here but i only have to test it on the
exponential session until of these
vectors
so you can see here that this can be
seen as a monomial so my function here
is an analytic function with infinitely
many parameters so if we look at an
example and we compute this nonlinear
morphism we get vectors such that this
coefficient has to be like this don't
try to a computer okay and if we try to
to compute the semantics of program will
get something which looks like that it
like this why so this is a program which
is recursively define it test twice its
input if it gets two different values
its terminate or if not its start again
it can feel you can feel it through anja
but here we call that we are in a call
by name setting so that means that each
time we see x.x we will compute it so we
really can get different values the
thing is here that we we do have a
problem of the phone ability because
here is the best the biggest coefficient
that we can get by interpreting program
but here you see that our morphisms can
have bigger coefficients so there are a
lot of morphisms that cannot be defined
defined as the interpretation of a
program also we have this is their
meaning to these coefficients in terms
of numbers of files or
application yes this is representing two
things the probability of getting this
this multisets and the number of passes
to get this multi set that is why it is
bigger than one
so also we have this problem of the fine
ability we have full abstraction the the
adequacy Direction is quite easy and for
the full abstraction we had to resume by
contradiction and suppose that these two
matrices a difference so they differ on
one index and the trick is to define
testing terms that do not depend on M or
n but that depends on the index on which
steady fur then we use the analogy city
in the regularity of our function to 200
so that means that our testing terms
depend on parameters and we need to find
parameters we need to to make to vary
our parameters so that we have different
these are analytic functions so if they
differ we know that there is one point
on which the different and we use this
proper this property to define our
testing terms regulate it means when you
have two different tonight in the rare
case when we have two different and
analytic functions you can find a point
on which study is different again so we
were super people on this result but we
forgot something that's the problem with
a theorist there is a growl for
abstraction and then there is a
practical the practical thing so we have
this one to be able to encode pove
sticker algorithm and we we fight anyway
let's look at this problem we have an
array with 0 and 1 cells and we want to
find an indexer of a cell containing 0
so the the idea is just to anomaly
choose
and in the exit test if the if it is
zero cell if yes you just output the D
index but in PCF we cannot do this
storage thing thing so what we can do is
just try we met this but what happen is
we are in call in a cabal name city so
first I choose randomly an index I find
0 cell and then I choose randomly
another index and I output it so it was
a nice story but we we we believe we all
trust in semantics so we decided to look
more closely on the the interpretation
of that and we discover that on this
interpretation we can define we can
interpret the storage operator why
because we can interpret a contraction
and co weakening that allows us to
duplicate or to erase natural numbers so
we were able to put this storage /
operator in the in the syntax and then
to interpret our probabilistic algorithm
but we will not still satisfied with
this we wanted to know on which types
can we find a storage operator so what
we would do the structures that we need
is the contraction and co-occurring and
we realized that khwaja browser are the
solution because the the code because
the when we apply the common are bound
to an objector we have a common area
Structure every Cuadrilla's on this
common onda will inherit from this
Community commander in structure so if
we have recommended social values can be
stopped so the next step was to
to try to define a class of types that
are interpreted as co algebras so
because one is a common and bankex is a
coil Jabbar and then Kwazii bizarre
stable but by tanza co-product and fix
pants so now we we were able to
interpret types like at such as matts
streams actually lazy streams and this
that's the that is the type of list of
cabin so we finally get this
probabilistic called i push values that
have been introduced 20 years ago by a
polity and the idea is as follows so we
have two different kinds of types we
have the positive types so we have bank
sigma we have the tensile of two
positive types we have the copper duct
and we have the possibility of making
fixed pants and we have general types
which can be positive or linear linear
application of a positive type on the
left and general type on the right we
also have two kinds of terms we do have
values and general programs so for the
values we have the units term we have
the stank of a program or the box of our
program we have passed because in the di
lammermoor category the tensor is a gate
agent product so here we have passed we
have the construction for the product
and for the the fixed panic right the
fixed point of times in four terms and
we have the possibility of making a
thing of open opening discern to think
opening the box we do have a linear
application and a linear abstraction so
if you want to encode the usual
application we need to use the linear
application and the boxing we are able
to incur the natural numbers
enter to encode the storage operator for
positive types we still have probably
stick for obstruction we had to work a
lot to to have this now the the easy
Direction is the full abstraction
because it was roughly the
generalization of the fluctuation
propecia for probity PCF but for
adequacy we had to work a lot because we
had to undervalue separately because we
are using fixed point of types so we had
to use a lot a lot of actually no trees
but combined lots of of tools such as
Stepanek thing be uttered annuity bit
tricker of fixed points of parallel path
of logical relations and we have to we
had to combine all of this in a mixture
and the crucial ingredient is the
density so you remember functions of
type long x 2 wire to know them we only
have to test them on this kind of points
because of them cities these points are
coachable qualified points and it is the
same thing for all the positive types to
know a function from a positive types /
general type I only have to test it on
quad right points and it is really the
key ingredient of the proof that's true
because it seems surprising or say
you're right kind of you only need to
look up the diagonals we're having
things of the just copy I have no
intuition it's just working from you at
the moment that I hope I get final
energy
okay so i think i can conclude them so
we were looking for a functional
language that is suitable for writing
probabilistic programs and we we finally
found out political by push value which
is an extension of policies co variable
value it combines call by name and call
by value values the opposite of positive
types so that they can be duplicated or
is erased according to their communal
commune with the structure and we we can
programs can under base types such as
nuts streams and other times and we have
full abstraction and I just want to make
a comment quick comment here this for
abstraction result doesn't need to make
a questions such as the free abstraction
44 game semantics it's really we we do
not touch on the on the morphisms to get
the free abstraction present so the next
steps are to move from discrete
probability to continuous one and also
to try to combine non non determinism
with probabilities so I think we can
define a non-deterministic manada on the
linear category and what we have to do
is to extend it on the nominal one and
another direction would be to interpret
functional relative programming because
now we can interpret streams in this
category and see here we can have more
information of such reactive programs
thank you for your intention
so I guess this is going to be a comment
so someone might ask so why do you get
full abstraction this setting with our
attention that so hard to do another I
think this is something it's actually
very interesting because if you do for
example it's EPO semantics and you try
to make it fully abstractly run into
things like the parallel or which exists
in the semantics so the interesting
thing to me is to a parallel or in this
car ballistic setting and you end up
getting negative coefficients for
example the probability that one of two
coins gives you heads is something like
2p minus Q squared that it's exactly the
absence of the negative coefficient
somehow which prevents the into a fully
abstract model and I think it's very
interesting so congratulations on
definition of the explanation modality
so notes in the assumption that when you
pick several times same type you pick
independently is there any hope for
extending things to have an exponential
that allows some kind of dependence
between the successive choices so we
didn't try and try to define an
exponential with this kind of dependent
a non-independent things but what we
know is that the this exponential is the
free one so that means that you will
whatever you will construct so you will
have to be able to to construct a filter
from this exponential to dear to the
other
yeah coming back to the sort of nervous
you're getting full abstract models so
in the pure PCF case we know that it
that active in some sense there can't be
a quotient free for the abstract
construction because of loaders there's
a decidability thing right so it depends
what features you add to the pure
functional setting whether you need the
quotient or not so for example the game
semantics which I guess ansara brass
vomited for probabilistic pc at with
state doesn't need a quotient as indeed
is true for other three are moments when
you have steak and some sense here
you're sort of sort of wonder if you're
close to having state by having our form
of state not a full sort of thing by the
fact that you know the way you're
representing the coin as it were in this
sort of consistent fashion so there may
be something also in the thinking about
why this happens that isn't that
elephant well actually the other thing I
wanted to ask is usually with coherent
spaces you have stability as emotionally
where's that does that what happens to
that in this picture so it done
so the study and the analytic functions
here k can be like a generalization of
stay stable function right does it
usually there's but you built it enough
that you're sitting inside the there's
no conflict with it because usually
receive all functions are incomparable
with the Scott continuous functions want
to go to higher order things for them
isn't happening here I don't know where
Cassidy so I was the what excited and
anxious to see that you want to do with
deal with continuous probably things so
usually that involves working with
polish spaces of some kind of metric
space I'm wondering how all this
apparatus of coherent spaces is going to
be built on top of that ya know I I
don't have that I prefer first two to
check whether I want to do it opens
the other issues well thank you very
much
[Applause]